[Music]
we are kicking off national teacher
appreciation week today so we're going
to start by highlighting a local
teacher's innovation that's taking art
to the next level mary jane belliesa
takes us to tyrone thompson elementary
school
for art specialist laura malecki art is
her perfect craft having a passion for
what you do and spreading the word
for teaching in a positive light i feel
is really impactful she's known for
thinking outside the box i've always
been a lifelong learner every year i am
doing something new either with the
state
or with the district or at my school to
try new things coming up with new ways
to be creative in her field and using
art to tap into social and emotional
development right now i'm currently
close to being certified through a
program called breathe for change so the
goal is to after school do a class here
at tyrone thompson for yoga and
mindfulness
with that certificate
also right now i'm working with the
state to
create for the very first time an art
curriculum at the state level for
elementary school principal robert
hinchliff says malecki's love for her
students and their growth is inspiring
to see teachers who struggle they
struggle because they haven't been able
to get to know students on a personal
level but miss malecki
is fantastic of that she knows every
student by their first name she knows
something about them i think that's key
my art teacher was an inspiration for me
and so i was very excited to go into art
and i've been doing art for over 18
years here at ccsd reporting from tyrone
thompson elementary school mary june
vallieza live local now